I think it is true that one of my major
occupations has been power not only
political but also social economic power
probably because I was born in a in a
country and in a in a region in which
power was synonymous of brutality of we
we have had so many kind of
dictatorships in Latin America
things are changing fortunately but when
I was young when I was a boy Latin
America was a region full of military
dictatorships and and that was
synonymous with brutality with the in
the brutal imposition you know of ideas
of attitudes of behaviors so this is a
kind of theme or subject that reappear
constantly in my in my in my work and I
think in in my stories that is always a
great respect and admiration for people
that in spite of this kind of
environment in which force brutality are
the main reasons to to behave and to to
act and to fulfill your daily life are
able to resist to fight and to
demonstrate that this is not fatigue
that things can change that life can be
better that societies can be
fear that they are and I think in this
kind of fighting against the established
order and reach themselves and Richard
let's say a superior kind of moral value
I think this kind of people are the
heroes of my my stories
a knight in a way all this is more or
less synthetized
in this description of the reason for
why the the Swedish Academy gave me the
Nobel Prize